ce soir je vais vous parler d'amour et
de pédagogie
l'amour c'est une émotion c'est
indicible alors j'ai dit je choisis de
dire aimer parce qu' aimer ces données
c'est offrir c'est savoir attendre ces
savoirs pleuré aussi pleuré de joie ou
pleurer de tristesse c'est se sacrifier
parfois on le fait souvent vis-à-vis de
l'autre mais je crois qu'on peut le
faire vis-à-vis d'eux soit la pédagogie
c'est transmettre c'est simple quand
j'ai demandé à mon petit garçon de 10
ans ce que lui inspirait les deux mots
amour et pédagogie il m'a répondu bah
l'amour c'est aimer puisse aimer ses
élèves la pédagogie c'est après donc tu
aimes ce que tu fais sans hésiter non
non tu hésites mais tu n'hésites pas à
hésiter et tu fais pas semblant
et j'ai trouvé qu'il avait résumé en ces
quelques mots ce que je vais tenter de
vous faire partager ce soir avant de
commencer je vous propose de regarder
quand je regarde ce nouveau né je suis
toute douceur toute protection toute
sécurité tout confiance
il n'y a rien qui me fasse peur il est
abandonné et je peux le protéger mais ce
tout petit va grandir et dans ce tout
petit il va y avoir la créativité
l'imagination la bravade l'envi de créer
l'envié de croire que tout est possible
la capacité de créer un monde imaginaire
qui va brusquement exister c'est
l'innocence et la puissance est bien que
nous avons été ce nouveau né nous avons
tous été nouveau-né nous avons tous
était tout petit nous pouvons entrer en
contact avec ce que nous avons connu et
je l'appelle l'enfant intérieur
moi j'ai jamais pu - détacher mon enfant
intérieur
c'est cette créativité cette imagination
cet optimisme cette énergie cette
volonté de vouloir tout transformer j'ai
été taxée par d'oka ou d'aucune
d'angélisme en qui j'ai jamais voulu
endosser le rôle de l'adulte l'adulte ou
savez ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
être abouti vous vous sentez abouti vous
abouti à quoi avoir terminé à voir tout
explorer ne plus rien avoir à découvrir
non alors j'ai dû apprendre à composer à
collaborer à étouffer un petit peu cet
enfant intérieur qui parfois prenait
trop de place et qui salit et mal du
rôle d'adulte qu'on attendait de moi
mais j'ai réussi
la preuve je suis pédiatre
quand j'étais petite fille
je voulais être maîtresse je pense comme
beaucoup de familles si comme beaucoup
d'hommes peut-être on a tous voulu être
maîtresse non mais moi c'était pour de
vrai c'était pour de vrai j'avais
vraiment envie
c'est comme si j'avais su que jamais je
pourrais me détacher de mon côté enfant
et que j'avais envie de passer du temps
avec les enfants mais j'ai fait médecine
évidemment pour devenir pédiatre quand
j'étais petite fille aussi mes parents
m'ont emmené en voyage c'est que les
voyages forment la jeunesse est moins
gaie dans beaucoup de pays mais lorsque
j'ai préparé ce dock ce soir je me suis
rendu compte que le voyage qui me venait
à l'esprit on le prépare ans c'était en
inde en inde j'ai eu le spectacle de ces
enfants pauvres abandonné malheureux
estropiés affamés et c'est comme si je
m'étais confondues pendant un instant
avec ses enfants et je me suis juré à ce
moment là quand je serai grande
j'adopterai alors mon mari et moi nous
avons fait deux enfants et nous en avons
adopté deux autres
bien sûr c'est une goutte d'eau dans
l'océan des enfants malheureux sur terre
mais je peux vous dire pour eux deux
c'est un fleuve quand j'étais petite
fille aussi j'ai été élevée par une
nounou qui était la bonté et la
générosité incarnée
elle ne savait pas être méchante elle ne
savait pas être fielleuse elle avait
toujours de bonnes raisons pour
expliquer ce qui se passait elle voyait
toujours qu'ils avaient un bon côté aux
choses et elle m'a appris à ne pas
envier ne pas être jalouse de ce que je
n'avais pas j'ai eu par ailleurs avec
l'éducation de mes parents la
l'apprentissage de la volonté de la
détermination de la discipline
jusqu'à parfois la névrose
obsessionnelle aller jusqu'au bout
transcender mais limite dépasser mes
limites
donc j'ai pu combler ses rêves d'enfant
j'ai pu rester en lien avec cet enfant
intérieur
et puis outre tout ça et la cuillère en
argent que j'avais dans la bouche je
suis né avec une formidable réserve
d'énergie
alors plutôt que de la développer à
houspiller ma famille à nettoyer mon
appartement j'ai décidé de consacrer
cette énergie à développer ce que
j'avais je croyais de merveilleux que je
crois encore de merveilleux c'est ce
lien ce contact avec mon enfant
intérieur
quand je me suis installé dans mon
cabinet de pédiatrie j'ai très vite
voulu dépasser mon rôle de soignant j'ai
voulu très vite entré en en relation
avec l'enfant j'avais cette compétence
magnifique extraordinaire de pouvoir
entrer en relation avec l'enfant au delà
de mon âge de ma fonction de mon
apparence et donc j'ai voulu développer
ça pour pouvoir le développer pour
pouvoir le faire
savamment j'ai fait des formations je
suis allé me former en programmation
neurolinguistique mon langage propre en
communication facilitée qui est un moyen
de communication avec les handicapés non
communicants non parlons je me suis
formé dans les stratégies
d'apprentissage en communication non
violente et en ethno psychiatrie et j'ai
fait ma sous pédagogique et elle
marchait mais pour vérifier qu'elle
marchait vraiment au delà de l'apparence
au delà du rôle au delà de
l'appartenance je suis parti en mission
humanitaire en afrique pour travailler
dans les écoles en afrique dans les
hôpitaux en afrique et ça a marché
alors ce soir je vais pas vous
développer ma pédagogie on est j'ai une
soirée de l'amour alors comment mieux
parler de l'amour quand dix ans amour et
pédagogie en parlant du parent pédagogue
avant de vous parler du parent pédagogue
j'ai envie de vous raconter une vieille
histoire que vous connaissez tous c'est
le sacrifice d'abraham d'isaac sais pas
trop dieu a choisi abraham pour être un
leader
il lui a appris patiemment tout ce qu'il
était nécessaire de savoir pourquoi rang
dieu et pour devenir un leader
il a été patient avec lui et il a
demandé à abraham la patience il a fait
attendre longtemps à bram et sarah avant
d'avoir un enfant
et puis son rêve a été comblé à kenny et
puis voilà qu abraham se fait demander
par dieu va sacrifier son fils
abraham l'anéantît abassourdi
décontenancé la folie ne comprend pas
que ce dieu auquel il avait confiance
qui l'avait suivie depuis des années lui
demande un tel sacrifice mais sûr que
quelque chose le dépasse il y va arriver
sur la colline aux rochers sacrificielle
de lui dit non non non a réparé être est
il ya un bélier qui accroché là juste
derrière l'arbuste sacrifie ce bélier
alors le parent pédagogue
c'est avant tout l'élan du coeur c'est
l'amour c'est le désir d'avoir un enfant
c'est le désir de faire cet enfant de le
découvrir c'est le désir et l'amour
inconditionnel de lui ouvrir le livre du
monde
page après page de regarder son regard
lorsqu'il découvre de se regarder soi
même en train de lui faire découvrir et
de regarder la relation qui se crée
pendant cette découverte et nous pouvons
retrouver tout cela parce que nous avons
été enfant nous avons eu cette innocence
nous avons eu cette imagination
nous avons eu cet abandon à la
découverte du monde mais quand j'aime
quand j'aime je protège je sécurise je
mets à cadre pour le protéger pour me
protéger pour protéger l'amour et j'ai
confiance dans le cadre que je mets
parce que j'ai confiance dans la qualité
de mon amour si je veux bien aimé j'ai
aussi besoin de regarder deux touchés et
c'est à ce moment là dans ce contact
particulier des échanges de regards et
de toucher qui fait que plus rien
n'existait que nous sommes ensemble
enfant intérieur à enfant intérieur lui
il est encore enfant et moi je sais je
peux y aller pour bien aimé il faut bien
alimenter
alors comment mieux nourrir que
d'alimenter les points forts de nos
enfants que de les renforcer dans leurs
ressources positive non pas pour leur
faire croire qu'ils peuvent tout faire
non certainement pas et pas plus que
doux mais d'avoir une juste estime
d'eux-mêmes d'appuyer sur leurs points
d'excellence de favoriser l' exemplarité
pas que nous soyons parfait mais que
nous sachions transcender nos propres
limites et sans cesse lorsque l'on est
en contact avec un enfant nous
transcendons nos propres limites et si
nous transcendons nos propres limites
nous nous connaissons donc chaque parent
est un bon parent parce qu'ils aident
l'enfant à se connaître
il aide l'enfant à transcender ses
propres limites et du coup le parents
découvrent ce qu'est la vie il apprend à
désapprendre au contact de l'enfant il
apprend à observer regarder faire comme
si c'était la première fois
comme s'il était lui aussi en train de
vivre le j'apprends en fait il fait
comme le petit prince s'entend dire par
le renard
l'essentiel est invisible pour les yeux
il ne se voit qu'avec le coeur et je
pense que nous pouvons voir avec le
coeur bien au delà des apparences en ur
connectant à notre enfant intérieur
et quand nous avons aimé que nous avons
donné que nous avons protégé que nous
avons cadré que nous avons su remettre
en perspective les règles en des moments
de calme parce que c'est toujours la
relation quitte à privilégier pas le
cadre si la relation n'existe que par
l'existence du quart de la relation je
vaux rien donc la relation prime par le
cadre oui quand nous avons fait tout ça
nous avons commencé à jouer notre rôle
de tuteur notre rôle de tuteur cdd à
aller vers l'avant de pousser vers le
haut c'est pas s'unir
c'est se relier et quand nous avons
cette conscience de notre rôle de tuteur
nous pouvons sacrifier le contrôle et ça
c'est l'accomplissement de notre rôle de
passeur de notre rôle de parent
pédagogue
c'est notre rôle que de donner à
l'enfant la puissance la sécurité le
guidage jusqu'à ce qu'il puisse aller
tout seul
nous restons le tuteur nous resterons
toujours la ressource profonde positive
de notre enfant mais nous saurons que
nous existons en dehors de ce rôle
auquel nous sommes pas unis ne nous
sommes pas confondu nous pouvons donner
à nos enfants l'envi la puissance
l'extraordinaire potentiel de faire de
chaque instant de leur vie quelque chose
d'extraordinaire si nous le vivons au
quotidien
si nous nous rendons compte à quel point
c'est une merveille sans cesse
renouvelée que de constater que nous
avons un enfant que nous l'avons fait
que nous le regardons vie peut nous le
regardons tandis que nous l'aidons à
aboutir si nous avons pu et su aimer
aimer l'autre s'aimer soi même être en
lien avec cet enfant intérieur qui se
débarrasse de toutes les couvertures
d'hypocrisie ou de rôle social ou
professionnel si nous savons rester en
contact avec cet enfant intérieur qui
est la sincérité l'innocence la
puissance en fait c'est nous avons gardé
le ticket pour le pays imaginaire de
peter pan si nous savons aller dans le
pays des enfants sauvages sauvage
pourquoi pas parce qu'ils n'ont pas
encore toutes ces couches culturel ils
savent créer le monde par leur
imagination et le monde existe deux
mondes existera mieux si les imaginez si
nous savons nourrir en favorisant la
curiosité intellectuelle pas en
l'imposant mais en suscitant en ayant
une patience
fern mais présentait douce faisant
confiance à ce que nous avons su donner
pour que la nouveauté puisse arriver à
la conscience de nos enfants à qui sa
rivale a déployé à la restituer si nous
avons été suffisamment fort pour pouvoir
protéger complètement et mais
complètement puis petit à petit devenir
le tuteur être à proximité tout 12
proximité sont nous confondre si nous
avons su faire tout cela
je crois que nous pourrons dire tu seras
un homme mon fils
merci